Amazon and MGM start putting their money
where their mouth is they're a big big
plans for Stargate welcome to Sidetrack
your Sci-Fi TV movie channel
[Music]
if you are a regular site tracker you'll
know that we've been following the
Stargate story from the very beginning
we've been able to exclusively tell you
over and over again what's going on
behind the curtain at Amazon and MGM and
I'm going to be able to exclusively tell
you some very interesting pieces of
information once again
but before I do I just want to very
quickly recap where we're at right now
the movie plan that again we exclusively
told you first seems to be the way this
is going now unless something really
changes Jennifer Salk is really really
pushing for a cinematic movie of
Stargate and people like Michael Wright
who's currently head of NVM plus who was
actually opposed to this idea initially
do seem to be coming on board I'm
hearing more and more Whispers that
actually they're starting to form a much
bigger plan for this project than maybe
we realized now we've been talking about
a franchise of Stargate for quite some
time a movie followed by a series but it
seems that Amazon and MGM are really
ready to put their money where their
mouth is Jennifer Steven a close friend
of the channel and the you know we this
is an MGM inside that we've seen on
dialog8 Etc several times always talks
about the project being a tentpole
project for Amazon and MGM that meaning
that really is a central project for the
channels and will be really a big
project for MGM now I can tell you
exclusively that in recent marketing
meetings this has been talked about as
the being the Sci-Fi project for Amazon
and MGM for the next decade at least at
times we've questioned whether there was
really enough confidence in the Stargate
brand but what we're starting to seeing
now is there's not just confidence
there's masses of confidence
so the movie at first we assumed when we
first started hearing that there was a
possibility of a Stargate movie that it
would be a straight to streaming film
maybe straight to Amazon Prime now we're
hearing it may actually be a cinematic
release which
to be honest is surprising to say the
least the budget for example the
difference between a streaming movie and
a cinematic movie is still huge it costs
a lot more money to get a movie to the
cinema so again it shows that confidence
and now hearing though as well that the
TV series that is going to follow the
movie will begin development immediately
and will actually be filmed either
immediately after or in part during the
production of the movie that means
they've actually already green lit the
TV series now that is again huge because
we always kind of assumed we would get
the movie and then if it did well we'd
get the series but no it looks like
Amazon and MGM have the confidence to
pull that trigger and that they're going
to be doing these back to back
so we're going to be going straight from
the cinema almost straight away into a
TV series now we can only assume that
those two projects are going to be
intertwined with each other that they're
going to exist within the same universe
obviously but also then the movie will
act as an opener for the series now guys
get into the comments can you tell me is
there a single time this has happened
before that a movie has gone to the
cinema and that a TV series is planned
for immediately afterwards where the two
projects are actually related the only
thing I can think of is maybe the
current Marvel universe or the TV series
in the movies you know influence each
other other than that I can't think of
anyone that's ever tried to do this
before now around Christmas I told you
that penguin and Parker was actually
negotiating really hard with Amazon and
MGM
um for the budgets Etc and that those
negotiations actually kind of collapsed
around Christmas time that they were
actually looking to get a green light on
this quite quickly but it got delayed
now it's currently being delayed because
all the studios are really focusing on
anything that's already in
pre-production because of the looming
strikes from the writers and then a
little bit later possibly even the
directors might go on strike so the
studios are focusing on making sure that
anything is in production at the moment
is going to be done and ready so that
they can carry on filming Etc if the
writers do go on strike so no new
projects are really getting announced or
at least no new projects are starting at
the moment just because of the risk that
they might have to stop almost
immediately
but what I did tell you previously was
that basically Amazon were looking at
trying to get the show around a budget
of five million dollars on average an
episode now I say that on average
because some episodes just cost more
than the others but a 10th episode
series they were looking at a budget of
50 million dollars and that then penguin
and Parker and Mark Fergus would be
allowed to spend more heavily on some
episodes and less on others as they saw
fit Mark Fergus was really pushing for a
budget closer to 10 million dollars he
wanted a hundred million dollars for his
10 episode series now it looks like they
have
started those negotiations again and
according to my source that was actually
in a marketing meeting very recently
they were talking about an average
budget of around eight million dollars
for an episode so for a 10 episode
series 80 million dollar budget so it
seems that they have literally just gone
well we want to spend five you want to
spend ten how about we just spend eight
okay everyone's happy but in this
marketing meeting they also talked about
the production budget of the strike to
cinema movie now this I think is a
little bit disappointing
the recent budget for Ant-Man um
quantumania which isn't a very good film
it's got brilliant bits but generally a
bit disappointing was 200 million
dollars the budget for the Avatar movies
has been ridiculous
a billion squillion you know we just we
just don't know the budget obviously for
the recent um Lord of the Rings the
rings of power Series has been kind of
ridiculous so you would expect a budget
of what 150 maybe 180 million dollars
for a straight to cinema Stargate movie
but the budget they're talking about was
more like 80 to 90 million dollars now
that is don't forget the production cost
it's how much they expect the movie to
actually cost to make it's not including
marketing etc etc which can you know be
another 50 on top of the actual cost of
the movie so we are looking at you know
maybe around 150 million dollars overall
budget for the film but the 80 to 90
million dollars in production that is a
little bit disappointing
but speaking to somebody else that I
know that used to work at MGM and now
does work um in another field within the
industry he actually said that those
budgets might be a little bit uh
misleading he's basically said the fact
that a movie and then a series have been
greenlit together basically and that
they've already sort of mentioned that
these will be filmed sort of at the same
time tends to suggest that perhaps
they're going to share things like
Studio space
sets special effects and so on and so on
what you're kind of getting is a two for
one deal you can spend money and do
things on the movie that will then
basically be free for the series or vice
versa you could build a set for the
series
that would come out of that budget that
then you use in the movie basically for
free she says it's actually a very
clever way of doing this on a budget
Amazon are a business in the end of they
and they don't like to spend money where
they don't have to they are looking for
a production partner who I think more
and more likely is going to be Sony but
we still don't know for certain to share
some of the production costs to share
some of the risk but also to share the
expertise something that Sony has in
Spades so on one hand I think that this
budget of maybe eight million dollars an
episode
is pretty good that's up there with Star
Trek budgets for the last few years
maybe not Picard season three that was a
little bit more expensive but it is up
there in around What discovery cost
what's strange new Worlds cost
um for a big Sci-Fi show particularly in
the current market that really shows
confidence the 90 million dollars for
the movie I do find a little bit
worrying
um but only in the respect that I would
have expected maybe a third more
but again if they're doing these two
projects together
it actually might mean we get a lot more
bang for our book on the screen if you
also think about if they don't have big
name actors in the movie so I'm thinking
about sort of
um Starship Troopers back in the day was
100 million dollar film when it was made
but it all went on the special effects
Etc they paid almost no money to the
major actors big Hollywood actors today
still cost 20 30 million dollars
potentially that would be a third of
this budget
but I'm being told over and over again
that is not where I was in an MGM are
planning to go with this they do not
want any big name actors even though
they did consider people like Miles
Teller they're going to bring a lot of
the actors from the original series back
they're going to bring in other
character actors that you'll sort of
like oh I know him from that thing I saw
once but you won't actually know their
name
and you know the kind of actor I'm
talking about and I don't mind that at
all because let's be honest
Michael Shanks Amanda Tapping
Christopher Judge so on and so on were
actors I didn't know before sg1 but now
I cannot wait to see in a movie and how
much money would you really have to
spend to get Richard Dean Anderson back
as Jack O'Neill it's not going to be in
the 20 30 million dollar area
so they're not going to be spending a
massive portion of the budget on actors
but what they are going to do is spend
decent money on actors we actually want
to see so this news coming out of their
marketing meetings and again this is
only a marketing meeting you do have to
remember that these are people that are
talking about what are they going to do
when this gets made how are they going
to promote it how are they going to push
forward now they will have had the
information from higher up so I'm
actually certain that the numbers they
were talking about were accurate but you
still have to remember that until they
actually start producing and a budget is
actually formally agreed these figures
can change
but it does look like the plans are
being laid down and that those plans are
big
they are not just going to be doing a
Stargate on a budget they're going to be
doing a Stargate that they plan to blow
our minds with and I cannot wait from my
sources I know that at MGM they consider
Stargate to be the sleeping giant of
sci-fi the giant is Awakening and Amazon
really believes it has a franchise here
to go up against Star Trek and maybe
even go a little bit further because
Star Trek hasn't got a movie going to
cinema
just saying but guys get to the constant
what you think these plans do seem to be
solidifying we are starting to get a few
ideas of numbers and budget Etc and we
are starting to get inside what Amazon
and MGM are really thinking about for
Stargate get to the comments and tell me
exactly what you think about these plans
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
please go over to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where you can get most
of our new videos first and for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel you get to see them
without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]